et si les commerces de proximité c'était
finalement l'avenir les 260 habitants de
fait La Vineuse ne diront pas le
contraire puisqu'il plébiscite le
barbazar qui est ouvert depuis trois
mois au sein de leur village situé aux
frontières de l'Indre-et-Loire et de la
Vienne le commerce a été relancé par
deux 49 qui ont décidé de dire adieu à
Paris et à son stress en investissant
l'ancienne école communale regardez
il y a 8 mois encore ce lieu était une
salle de classe depuis le 1er décembre
c'est le bar où tout fait La Vineuse se
retrouve pour papoter se détendre
derrière le comptoir Serge 50 ans cet
ancien styliste parisien a décidé de
changer de vie et d'ouvrir un snack bar
dans ce village de 260 habitants entre
Richelieu et Châtellerault dans cette
aventure également Vincent son compagnon
photo plasticien et désormais cuistot
j'ai acheté ma maison à fait la bineuse
sur un coup de tête en tombant amoureux
déjà du lieu de la région
et puis pendant une dizaine d'années en
fait à faire l'aller-retour sur Paris
c'était de plus en plus tragique et
toujours plus difficile de fermer la
maison le dimanche et après les vacances
et ça mûrit doucement la covid a
beaucoup participé aussi à la prise de
décision en disant que il faut vivre
autrement il faut vivre autre chose
cette
occupation de l'école est temporaire le
temps de rénover l'ancienne boulangerie
du village pour y implanter
définitivement le commerce en attendant
le retour des habitants et plus que
prometteur les gens sont très
accueillantes
l'ambiance est parfaite il y a toujours
du monde ici on mange bien on boit bien
convivialité il y a du mélange d'âge les
petits les vieux quoi et puis bah c'est
bon quoi je pense c'est bon pour le
moral mais pas que pour la vie de la
communauté pour moi je me doutais que ça
allait fonctionner parce que connaissant
les habitants du village je savais que
avoir un lieu comme ça pour se
rencontrer c'était
intéressant aussi c'est les gens étaient
en attente de ça
le déménagement du commerce n'est pas
prévu avant le printemps alors si vous
passez dans le secteur faites un détour
pour découvrir ce lieu atypique et faire
une petite gratouille à zizi la mascotte
du troquet